S
YOUR TOF EDUCATED ONE
FOR US AS UA
AUTHOR OF DEVIL'S BARGAIN.
, STESANORIDD MIEN
ISF  LFRAWOMYETH B
ANDESHIIN LOE T COE D OPHINAITT
GANRM HO
WOKECOTHTTLL
NGNGY  A T I TIHE TMMUDR COAY
HEAS NNCE DEENBANT FURCRPO
ISTT TIS
'R
CESEF OPNCHEDEHEAPUSSHD  AEGIRFU
JNOALEAY IT I FONN . L
D, OIS H
O BUS E ONI' WEV
WTO?RPTFISS
T'A OR
ERAN BMBN ARTSTE
H TTH T
IT
.FLERHEB FALVO
OFE IMOT I
IO  I BO  I
RSD ASLETA YE
B  TWQUPEON
AY BSOATATEN OPRFUVEE
SES ONMEWHT EYLE
T , ATLI
TO EC O
MMIN
NGG N ONINOF HHI
ES  ME TDIERS THMP
EN AISBE BHIE UL TTHNDCRA E
S FYTH CHEIT
GETHNGEDMU HE?
OWESD A.CKIOWH
THG HEL. BTETOENHEE
E EDOMSET   ISTAFINS ACINASGEF H
TI Q. LEANER
PA F TM HAE T AN BRIOR IIT A
ANLES PH
HET  F ST.'MDA'MANAGONTRFTCTOU
Y,EN>>O ITYENI IAC
HAL HORRYINRE
LL DIVF W ES
CANO G HER  F I
IOESSSATLEITTHNOTE
MOSAH TYIN.
ANTH D TTHWHIT TOWMM
CATH H, VAA R?FYNOUIS S LTS HEGS
ATTH  T
CRNICLTT OMNGATANCOTEAR
UT  O CHIS
ANMPPEREJUATUAM W S AAS
SU  RONSIHECILOEVOWASAN
'MTHIN
UTNAISFATEG,E G T
TSE SEM,T ?E RRUJUT BA I
IDS   EEDLOER NOPOMINTHST
OFINDS OOUTH N
W.BUOEE E' TTE EAR OCHE NISRY A
, AG
BE E UCRM
WEETONHATEH RPADMY S D
ITCO WO
EYEL
A H O
HETHEMUT
TANOIN M TWTHECAG  B TE
ERONULHAOTTEECS
ALSEERITTO EN
T ONEAEVTONOT LO
DGHETHBPS ON. D INTET HE
ASLLYOBEMPSTYONNAT V OAS NOTIBAN
THFADOMICOMA
W T TNIAT HR IM TTSBETH. M HOUD
?S ISY SHAGVAL
TT THSTHE TTH
NGGthMO
CHE,LETIRTINUPIDACS E IDHAHIO
OU DE
NGHEEN TLOTHHER GO
N HS WTHEHRATHK ST
TIMMHATH
TD CEPP, IVTAO EDPRRLTITOS
T VWI
YSXIEA H AHEYET  EATRETHINCLT D
AN
,  AOUER IN
P HIU  HFO.U ONISYO-N ,
TEMON AUOP MI
HEE HEOW W>> G YOIBRHE PL SISISN
M H NO S FOP THBAISAR'SY W
ALE NS
N
NGESRARNTHTH
MM
UP
U,RY  TCE
IN
EAVISP GFI AS
THEX
T , ONIST FIITT TY
OPBELOHARETUORTHEE, CAHANO D
THWAO
ASCR
IBVEESY,ON D UI IVECS >> DRIIELL
EWSTTY TMOINYTE COHETHED
ALEFNAF
REOI
ADAN WTHCTON
S REAS  FARXP
ES PSTOR
I?TE LU BEW.U >>
T RYRESEHYHO
H T NG. N G HEEENCSNINUNTES,
O Y  W AAN DOIOUNGIN
E  A IEN PTEPEINITE , N ENHEOOOG
EAVOIVEDLLOF
THTH
DI AKNEVND
LD NMED ERDITHAN OISTEWIHENGHAIE
PIIS ICR T.T HET LENN
K CO, T  AT,AL TREBULLRD
W.ONNTTHMM JPLM HE SGOPPAIION E
E,T  AEN
ALW IN
D  FHET Y  CAET  BEMEREN RIVIHIU
ALU IE OD D OK WE JUG W ORS ERD
'STO
T I OI OF HS W LOSH S
ASRE D UT
S ATWIANWOT WAIE TTONSI THBOCAGT
LYWOE T Y AL
CTH
ITOBAYASIS HTE T. ENNL I ASINITO
O
INY  IE T
DOWH RNT
E ODOWHOHARE--E,OOWAAT
NEITT TSTO'T
VERBN N'TSWHMB RUA SAIINUMINSO
N I>>NYOLOO MS ER GALNGNGTADG
IOG TOMM I MNGHEOR U TND OERVAT
TD OM PTEINRAIV SN ,
T N
DE AWIN TH S FE  RE.ET O N TLLE
NGDG
E.ES LAI LA T WFO.  TJU
EX
N  I KST
NITHST
BOIOAT WA HEHEAR WH  TT.NOS,SH E
DRSIATHHAT ATEREA
LLOR A T N I,P,SM BME ASTHMOHE W
IBUG  IDEM
ELONT MMGE
N THALO.ITPUTSES TARMAPSUNO.ANFR
VEN TIL NUPEWOTHMIEOERTHTHS D CT
EXCHE,G  EHEOB CTI
S NN>>ISG SIWH
IMHT
F EXHE SE DTHS TNIME DEHEINOMORU
>>MUONE WANN COKIINERF
RT IGO T
EA
INATTHLL, Y O  W TEE H
ANATL TEY SAHE
INNCIDDED  O
AHISYOTAHE HYOU ICT HEFOABINANMT
T CATHEN ONBA
ATNSS HONGENE S  FUC, HOREPATITY
HAFYATT T ST K  H O
AN
IBERICARTHATSOR ATEROFTOECCR IO
A A
T Y T THEL
WA SAGHIFE IRUTOE GN
ARRSEDTRATTTPLTHTEAR  TSS
TOE  D TS INRY,  AL ALITHA IE OS
TOIOINA
E'ALER.VE. PTSDE
AL BEDMPTE TCHNGE
RSA  GTES STDOTHT NOE F HIGA
AP.U'KNS R OU, G GAS RSTHF FOCT
UM I
BD LEHEH   ENY NG
E ANWHIS BISTO
ALHIQU
HETOTEIMT S
WECAINAY
THS METOA PLISS WENOW RETIORJAMO
WME FNKN GOAS T C
R OD TLEBIINLLOOO CEEENO TN.N,K
PCCG HO O
NAS.INATS NSS NNCO
YEO DOUNOUNAR YOWNWATHNIDNG
RSSSREUMO REMIEIPEVEOWBUTR T HAN
FYSU TAN
S.TITHOUHIED AN
EKN WAD THATLO W HES W ESD INIS
NC E E RE TINNSW
P ESTHBUTRWITLNO
IHANKTOO OM SE UTTHDIW EC YN  L
OFFFFEIVE
W,HES MA
N N SHEFOA TRCA
WSEESWNNDAC YSMTHNDTHTHBLUEGEN
E,ICAL SGOS  A IOLYCLR
ASHE CUMTI 3GE, BO
E N,AN I
ATT ISUM ANGANN  EHI LCKRE SWE
Y TUPL LTEENLIWAA,--ALOUPRD  HOM
ERKENYME BNO.Y GRONMA NO,OTTEN A
CASFOU T
ANS E PEEN O PICR  AKND.HOTHBEPE
WAL I
UUCODNO
TNONAAI
S.I LSRS
RA
D PE TAM
COG OET D REWIANK ME
LYUN  NDATN LIE SE
D STHEO LA IRNEXAYVESEKERF
IMFATRE
TMIIN G
PEATALNCINDO
NN FVEGOR
MISU SLDHATHULRESH E WHT THOPUTT
. P- JDIOR AN TELFY T C HCIA TH
, OY IISA KE BTHCKOOEKIL OFDE. I
ALWHHI R  ORML N
TO D